Thank you very much.
Now, I've got a story for you.
When I arrived off the plane,
after a very long journey from the West of England,
my computer, my beloved laptop,
had gone mad,
and had -- oh! -- a bit like that! --
and the display on it --
anyway, the whole thing had burst.
And I went to the IT guys here
and a gentleman mended my computer,
and then he said, "What are you doing here?"
and I said "I'm playing the cello and I'm doing a bit of singing,"
and he said, "Oh, I sort of play the cello as well."
And I said, "Do you really?"
Anyway, so you're in for a treat,
because he's fantastic, and his name's Mark.
(Applause)
I am also joined by my partner in crime, Thomas Dolby.
This song is called "Farther than the Sun."
(Music)
♫ Strung in the wind I called you ♫
♫ but you did not hear ... ♫
♫ And you're a plant that needs poor soil ♫
♫ and I have treated you too well ♫
♫ to give up flowers ... ♫
♫ Oh, I have been too rich for you ... ♫
♫ Farther than the sun from me ♫
♫ Farther than I'd have you be ♫
♫ And I go north, I get so cold ♫
♫ My heart is lava under stone ♫
♫ You are not worthy ♫
♫ You are not worthy ... ♫
♫ With your calculating eyes ♫
♫ spinning figures ♫
♫ you cannot see me ♫
♫ You cannot see me ... ♫
♫ And if I tell myself enough ♫
♫ I'll believe it ♫
♫ You are not worthy ♫
♫ The sea, it freezes over ... ♫
♫ to trap the light ♫
♫ And I'm in love with being in love ♫
♫ and you were never quite the one ♫
♫ In Gerda's eyes ♫
♫ Fragments of what you've become ♫
♫ And all the moths that fly at night ♫
♫ believe electric light is bright ♫
♫ You are not worthy ♫
♫ With your calculating eyes ♫
♫ Spinning figures ♫
♫ You cannot see me, no ♫
♫ And if I tell myself enough ♫
♫ I'll believe it ♫
♫ You are not worthy ♫
♫ Farther than the sun from me ♫
♫ Farther than I'd have you be ♫
♫ And I go north, I get so cold ♫
♫ My heart is lava under stone ♫
♫ You are not worthy ♫
♫ With your calculating eyes ♫
♫ Spinning figures ♫
♫ You cannot see me, no ... ♫
♫ And if I tell myself enough, I'll believe it ♫
(Applause)
Thank you very much.